[موسيقى]
أصبحت الاستدامة كلمة طنانة في لعبة
الجولف مع الكثير من المناقشات حول
الطرق الأكثر خضرة وأكثر كفاءة للعب
اللعبة. أنا هنا في الإمارات العربية المتحدة لتجربة
شكل فريد جدًا من اللعبة
[موسيقى]
لمعظم لاعبي الجولف.  هو شيء يجب
الخوف منه في ملعب الجولف حيث يتطلعون إلى
التنقل في طريقهم حول Lush Fairways
والمساحات الخضراء أثناء البقاء خارج المخابئ
ولكن بالنسبة لهذا الملعب فإن Sam هو نجم
العرض،
لذا فإن
تصميم ملعب الجولف بشكل أساسي مصنوع من
الرمال ومن الواضح أن
لدينا  الممرات الخاصة لدينا
قطراتنا الخاصة لدينا أه الفريد
نادي براونز ألكازار للجولف في أبو ظبي
ربما يكون أفضل نادي جولف رملي في العالم تم
افتتاحه في عام 1997، حيث تم استبدال المساحات الخضراء التي عادة ما
تجدها في ملعب الجولف
ببراونز حيث الرمال  تم
مزجه بالزيت المستخدم وضغطه
لإنشاء سطح أملس ومتساوي.
لم أر أي لاعب غولف قام بتجريب
براونز الذي لم يعجب
بسطحه الأملس، لذا فإن
هذا النوع من التجربة الفريدة لكل لاعب
غولف يعود تاريخه إلى  ديربي السبعينات والثمانينات
عندما كان X Oil Workers
متحمسين
لمسرحية [الموسيقى]
وكانت النتيجة نسخة من لعبة الجولف
حيث يكون العشب الوحيد الذي يمكن رؤيته هو العشب
الاصطناعي الموجود على السجادة التي يحملها
اللاعبون ليكون بمثابة
نقطة الإنطلاق  والسطح الذي ستضرب منه
عندما تكون الكرة على الممر السالك نظرًا
لعدم وجود عشب هنا، فسوف
تحصل على حصيرة بلاستيكية واحدة من
العشب الاصطناعي والتي يمكنك استخدامها
عندما تضرب الكرة عبر
الممر السالك  إذا كنت بعيدًا عن
الممر أو في المنطقة الوعرة، فلا
يُسمح لك باستخدام الخريطة، حيث
تكمن إحدى أكبر فوائد ملعب الجولف الرملي في هذه المنطقة في
الصيانة ونقص المياه اللازمة
للحفاظ على الممرات و  مظهر أخضر فخم
ولحسن الحظ لم نرغب في
إجراء مثل هذه الصيانة مثل ملعب الجولف النموذجي،
أعتقد أن هذا هو
ملعب الجولف الأكثر استدامة في دولة الإمارات العربية المتحدة،
يوجد في دولة الإمارات العربية المتحدة بعض الملاعب ذات الشهرة العالمية
والتي من
العدل أن نطلبها مع وجود الكثير من الخيارات في المنطقة  هل تمكنت الغزالة من
جذب أي من السكان المحليين للعب،
لدينا حاليًا حوالي 40 عضوًا، لذلك يمثل
تحديًا بالنسبة لنا أن
نعيد الأشخاص إلى
نادي الجولف ولكننا نعمل على تطوير
نادي الجولف بإضافة المزيد من الميزات في
ملعب الجولف، لذلك  نأمل أن يكون لدينا المزيد من
الأعضاء في بطولات المستقبل القريب
مثل فئة صحراء دبي
في الإمارات العربية المتحدة. قد تكافح الغزالة
لجذب أعضاء جدد ولكن مع
عروضها المستدامة إلى جانب
ملعب الجولف الرائع، يقدم هذا المكان
تجربة أود أن أحث جميع
لاعبي الجولف الذين يزورون الإمارات العربية المتحدة  لمحاولة
الأجنبية